now here for reaction arizona attorney
general and senate candidate mark
brnovich along with former acting ice
director and fox news contributor tom
homan uh tom uh let me start with you
because we hear these stories uh it we
don't there's not a lot of visuals
people don't see it so much you can kind
of become inured
to the the chaos to the tragedy of it
all but people are dying we don't see it
on tv like we do with ukraine uh you
know
you've been uh law enforcement involved
in this uh
where do you where does where is this
now where do you see it going and uh
what can what what do you think biden
can or will do which i think at this
point is nothing
well first of all your monologue you
rocked it you're right at every point
you made and look by administration
ain't going to fix this the byte
administration has been in power for 14
15 months they haven't done a single
thing to slow the flow nothing they've
done nothing to secure the border
everything they've done is how quickly
can we process migrants and release them
right now they're looking at 900 million
dollars to build soft sided facilities
for the surge that's coming so they can
process and release quicker and when you
process and release quicker that just
brings more and you're appointed by
inhumane policy let me make one point
we'll go to mark
the bite administrators keep saying the
trump policies are inhumane let me be
clear on this more migrants have died
under the first year of joe biden on u.s
soil than any year i can remember a
record number more migrants are dying
under joe biden and over a hundred
thousand americans have died over
overdose deaths of fentanyl comes across
that southwest border his policies are
inhumane and they're killing people
thank you for that reminder and it's
stark attorney general you've been down
to the border this is a human
catastrophe
we see it it is getting worse the
american people are shocked where
there's a war going on around the world
there's all kinds of viruses beyond
covid what did you see at the border
and are they getting any kind of a
handle on it because it's just so
overwhelming and yet there's no money
there's no assistance
what are you seeing down there
uh tammy thank you for having me on and
i literally was at uh in douglas today
and the douglas sector just in february
there was already nearly 40 000 people
either the gotaways or the give-ups that
tried to cross that sector and literally
only a thousand of them were turned away
so this is having a devastating impact
on our
our country and i will tell you that one
of the things that we know that uh
congress has been broken for so long and
the consequences of that have damaged
our country but when you combine that
with this the clown show that is the
biden white house it is devastating
because people are dying
you know we know we talk about these
numbers and sometimes you get numb to
them but literally people's daughters
nieces nephews are being killed in pima
county arizona the number one cause of
death now amongst young people is
fentanyl and drug overdoses so americans
are paying the cost in lives and
treasure and it's one of the reasons why
i've led the lawsuit on title 42 against
the bite administration why we sued him
over the public charge rule why we suit
him over his inability or unwillingness
to follow the law and deport people so
what the administration has done is
decriminalized and incentivized people
breaking the law you know that's a great
point obviously as the chaos tom gets
worse if a title 42 is removed it means
that there's going to be even more you
know additional crime uh more sex
trafficking more human trafficking the
more drugs coming across it's easy it's
bad enough when there's some security
but when there's complete chaos
it just emboldens uh the actors in this
even more doesn't it
yes it does and you're right on those
points and it's going to get worse and
let me tell you why because they've
already encountered 1.2 million so
they're on they're on a scale right now
to beat last year's numbers which was
historic
and they're going to blow them out of
water even in title 42 is in place and
they're so overwhelmed right now there's
been 67 000 got aways just last month 67
000 people entered this country wow that
weren't arrested and they come from 157
different countries if you don't think
that any of those 67 000 came from the
country that supports terrorism then
they're being ignorant this is a
national security crisis and if they if
they lift title 42 which are going to
that 67 000 is going to it's going to
swell to over 100 000 a month got a ways
we don't know who these people are
that's just scared the hell out of every
american this administration has created
a national security crisis that i've
never seen in my opinion and i think
that's that is the key phrase tom
attorney general that this is not an
accident it's not a mistake they're not
clueless that there is now it clearly
seems to be i think on its face
deliberate that this is policy that it's
not like bad policy that that no one's
listening to
this is the policy
what could the end game be here attorney
general when you've got a policy that is
as monstrous as this
tammy when you combine what is happening
on our southern border the national
security threat the increase in crime
what we are seeing is an attempt by the
left and whoever's talking in joe
biden's earpiece to radically alter and
change this country they are essentially
trying to socialize our economy
nationalize our election and overwhelm
our system and our neighborhood so i
think people become more dependent on
central authority this is the neo
marxist playbook and we see this
everything from trying to jam critical
race theory down our kids throats to
increase crime in our neighborhoods and
that's why i'm fighting to stop it all
right well thank goodness you're there
tom thank you so much for your
continuing work gentlemen thanks for
joining me now hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else